et lohan a eu la gloire c'est la chute
libre
ça a été la fibre mais au fil des années
ta sortie du loft l'euphorie retombe et
tu te retrouves de moins en moins
sollicités c'est pas que j'ai été de
moins en moins sollicités c'est que
c'est moi qui ai fait la bêtise d'être
mal entouré et de moi répandre aux
sollicitudes c'est ça alors un moment tu
as vraiment plongé dans la drogue
oui c'est ce que tu dis bien suffit pas
c'est comment ça s'est passé parce que
avant de rentrer dans l'offre wilko
nerfs se connaître ce succès ne souffre
que tu connaissais la drogue est ce que
tu étais donc donc dans ses délires ou
pas du tout non je n'étais pas du tout
mais j'avais 23 ans c'est pas le loft
comme on dit qui m'a fait plonger dedans
ça a été les mauvaises rencontres
j'avais 30 ans je suis tombé dedans
donc voilà et donc derrière
qu'est ce qui se passe il paraît que tu
disais tu dis à un moment que tu prenais
de la drogue au petit déjeuner oui c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui est qui et
alcoolique et qui boit son verre
d'alcool matin au réveil et ben moi je
prenais de la drogue au matin au réveil
tu prenais quoi la cauquenne c'est à
dire donc le matin au réveil tu te
réveiller il faut que je me prenais
genre j'en prenais je prenais un trait
way jusqu'au soir donc comment toute la
journée pour trouver la journée way et
entente dedans comme on tombe dans
l'alcool donc les gens ne font que boire
et je suis tombé dans la drogue comme on
tombe dans le port d'une aide et de la
drogue comme ça pour oublier pour
oublier ça ne devient pas dj quoi pour
oublier les gens qui étaient autour de
moi et qui me faisait du mal c'est qui
ces gens qui c'est autour de toi qu'est
ce qui s'est passé après le loft
ça a été un long temps après le loft
parce que pendant dix ans j'ai j'ai été
comme ça donc c était que dix ans plus
tard après le loft que je suis tombé
dans ses addictions la fusion mais dans
l'alcool sont bien la drogue
je voulais y obliger
je voulais oublier ma vie tous les
oublier ta vie je voulais oublier ma vie
qui me convenait pas oui